and david i can't keep you very long
because you've got a pressing
engagement that the world is waiting for
yep bye
[Laughter]
see i told you i told you does he have
children to shave
it's all grown back no you're you're
getting on a plane aren't you
yeah yeah um after this um i'm going to
los angeles we're going to be
shooting uh the friends reunion next
week so
i'm hopping on a plane um this afternoon
or the evening
and um yeah i'm gonna see everyone next
week for the first time in many years so
and i know you can't tell us anything
about it but just
can you tell us will you be ross or will
you be
david schumer i'll be i'll be myself
i'll be
i'll be david yeah there's nothing
there's nothing scripted
uh we're not in character um uh
yeah so it's it's all it's we're all
ourselves
um the real people um although there is
one section of it that i'm i don't want
to give away
but um where we we we all read something
so and it's been i mean it finished
nearly
17 years oh stop wow i know 17 years ago
so
have you been watching old episodes to
kind of gen up what the hell that'll
happen
it's really funny um i i i should have
been doing that
and i really have very little excuse but
i haven't been able to bring myself to
catch up on on the 236 episodes i need
to i guess i need to watch
a lot over the next five days wow